Et si votre cerveau n'arrive pas
à intégrer les mauvaises nouvelles concernant l'avenir,
vous verrez constamment la vie en rose.
Nous voulions donc savoir si nous pouvions changer cela.
Pouvions-nous modifier le biais d'optimisme des gens
en interférant avec l'activité cérébrale dans ces zones ?
Et nous avons un moyen de le faire.
Voici mon collaborateur Ryota Kanai.
Et il fait passer une petite impulsion magnétique
à travers le crâne du participant à notre étude
jusqu'à l'intérieur de son gyrus frontal inférieur.
Et en faisant cela,
il interfère avec l'activité de cette zone du cerveau
pendant environ une demi-heure.
Après ça, tout redevient normal, je vous assure.
(Rires)
Voyons donc ce qui se passe.
Tout d'abord, je vais vous montrer
la quantité moyenne de biais que nous voyons.
Donc, si je vous testais tous maintenant,
voici la quantité de bonnes nouvelles que vous retiendriez plus
par rapport aux mauvaises nouvelles.
Maintenant nous interférons avec la zone
dont nous avons trouvé qu'elle intégre les informations négatives dans cette tâche,
et le biais d'optimisme augmente encore plus.
Nous avons rendu les gens plus partiaux dans la manière dont ils traitent l'information.
Puis nous sommes intervenus dans la zone du cerveau
dont nous avons trouvé qu'elle intégre les bonnes nouvelles dans cette tâche,
et le biais d'optimisme a disparu.
Nous avons été très surpris par ces résultats
parce que nous avons pu éliminer
un biais profondément enraciné chez les humains.
Et à ce moment, nous nous sommes arrêtés et nous nous sommes demandés,
voulons-nous faire voler en éclat l'illusion de l'optimisme ?
Si nous pouvions le faire, voudrions-nous enlever aux gens le biais d'optimisme ?
Bien, je vous ai déjà parlé de tous les avantages du biais d'optimisme,
ce qui vous donne sans doute envie de vous y accrocher comme si votre vie en dépendait.
Mais il y a, bien sûr, des pièges,
et il serait vraiment stupide que nous les ignorions.
Prenez l'exemple de ce courriel que j'ai reçu
d'un pompier d'ici, en Californie.
Il dit : « Les enquêtes sur les décès de pompiers
contiennent souvent "Nous ne pensions pas que le feu allait faire ça"
même lorsque toutes les informations disponibles
étaient là pour prendre des décisions en toute sécurité. »
Ce capitaine va utiliser nos conclusions sur le biais d'optimisme
pour tenter d'expliquer aux pompiers
pourquoi ils pensent de cette façon,
pour leur faire prendre conscience de ce biais d'optimiste tout particulier chez les humains.
Un optimisme irréaliste peut donc conduire à un comportement dangereux,
à un effondrement financier, à une planification défaillante.
Le gouvernement britannique, par exemple,
a reconnu que le biais d'optimisme
peut rendre les personnes plus susceptibles
de sous-estimer les coûts et les durées des projets.
Ils ont donc adapté le budget des JO de 2012
en fonction du biais d'optimisme.
Mon ami qui se marie dans quelques semaines
a fait de même pour le budget de son mariage.
Et d'ailleurs, quand je lui ai demandé son propre risque de divorce,
il s'est dit certain que c'était zéro pour cent.
Ce que nous voudrions donc vraiment faire,
c'est nous protéger contre les dangers de l'optimisme,
mais en même temps garder espoir,
et bénéficier des nombreux fruits de l'optimisme.
Et je crois que nous avons un moyen de le faire.
La clé réside ici vraiment dans la connaissance.
Nous ne sommes pas nés avec une compréhension innée de nos biais.
La recherche scientifique doit les identifier.
Mais la bonne nouvelle est que la prise de conscience du biais d'optimisme
ne brise pas l'illusion.
C'est comme les illusions optiques,
pour lesquelles le fait de les comprendre ne les fait pas disparaître.
Et c'est bien, parce que cela signifie
que nous devrions être en mesure de trouver un équilibre,
de créer des plans et des règles
pour nous protéger de l'optimisme irréaliste,
mais en même temps garder espoir.
Je pense que cette caricature dépeint cela parfaitement.
Parce que si vous êtes l'un de ces pingouins pessimistes
qui ne croit tout simplement pas qu'il peut voler,
vous n'y arriverez certainement jamais.
Parce que pour faire des progrès quelconques,
nous devons être capables d'imaginer une réalité différente,
et puis, nous avons besoin de croire que cette réalité est possible.
Mais si vous êtes un pingouin extrêmement optimiste
qui saute tout en espérant aveuglément le meilleur,
vous pourriez vous retrouver dans un sale état lorsque vous heurterez le sol.
Mais si vous êtes un pingouin optimiste
qui croit qu'il peut voler,
mais qui ajuste ensuite un parachute sur son dos
juste au cas où les choses ne tournent pas exactement comme vous l'aviez prévu,
vous allez monter en flèche comme un aigle,
même si vous n'êtes qu'un pingouin.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)